[музика]
вітаємо і Ласкаво просимо до програми У
фокусі Європа Різдво не за горами для
тих хто святкує це час року коли можна
провести час зі своїми сім'ями
насолодитися святковими стравами та
обмінятися подарунками тут у Європі люди
також сподіваються на це незважаючи на
війну енергетичну кризу та інфляцію
красиво прикрашені ялинки та різдвяні
ярмарки створюють святковий настрій по
всій Європі протягом останніх кількох
тижнів Лондон особливо відомий своєю
святковою атмосферою центр міста весь у
вогнях як і торгові райони
але все менше і менше людей можуть
дозволити собі шопінг тут згідно з
лондонської статистикою більше чверті
жителів міста живуть за межею бідності
особливо страждають сім'ї через високу
інфляцію стрімке зростання цін на газ і
подорожчання продуктів харчування багато
людей опинилися за межею бідності деякі
сім'ї змушені робити важкий вибір між
їжею та опаленням тасхан намагається
допомогти тим хто вже не може допомогти
собі сам і чим більше Він допомагає тим
більше розуміє наскільки багато людей
потребують допомоги
черга перед громадською їдальною стає
довшою з кожним днем бідність у Лондоні
зростає
ця ситуація не дає спокою тазу кхану
Він знає що без нього і його приватного
продовольчого банку багато лондонців
голодували
Люди які працюють як чоловіки так і
жінки приходять щоб отримати доступ до
наших послуг
до нас приходять також пенсіонери тобто
зростає кількість людей які зазвичай не
відвідують такі місця
щотижня таскхан забезпечує їжею 15 тисяч
лондонців
волонтери громадської їдальні роздають
600 кілограмів їжі щотижня у чотирьох
пунктах роздачі на півночі Лондона зараз
Вони зайняті як ніколи де на русен
мати-одиначка Вона працює на півставки в
універмазі майже щотижня вона приходить
сюди щоб отримати їжу для себе своїх
двох маленьких синів і матері
інакше мені було б дуже важко з такою
інфляцією з таким зростанням цін це дуже
складно Я не знаю як я змогла б
впоратись
фарід Куба також приїжджає майже щотижня
і запасається продуктами тим що
залишається він ділиться із іншими
Мені стільки не треба Я просто ходжу і
роздаю це людям які не можуть самі
прийти сюди більшу частину я роздаю ТАС
Хан співпрацює із супермаркетами та
постачальниками вони жертвують їжу яку
вже не можна продати вона швидко
роздається це частина Його концепції
нуль відходів нуль голоду
Ми дякуємо людям які приходять і
користуються нашими послугами тому що
вони тим самим роблять послугу нам
розрив між багатими і бідними особливо
великий у Великій Британії у порівнянні
із іншими заможними країнами зростаючий
інфляція і високі ціни на енергоносії
призводять до того що все більше людей
опиняються за межею бідності особливо
сім'ї і з дітьми
містечко харлуб на півночі Англії не
виняток Тут живе Деніел бернсат зі
своїми дітьми
самозайнятий маляр хочу бути впевненим
що кобин і есмін завжди матимуть
достатню їжі але це легше сказати ніж
зробити
увімкнути опалення зараз розкіш
воно було вимкнене кілька днів мені
довелося похмуро чекати наступної
зарплати якоїсь копійки яку я зможу
отримати щоб увімкнути його теж
стосується і електрики ми вимикаємо
світло і сидимо в темряві
[музика]
в умовах інфляції що перевищує 10%
Деніел бернсайт змушена економити де
тільки може
іноді йому доводиться обходитись навіть
без гарячої їжі
Зараз нам доводиться робити вибір
вибираючи доводиться чи ми жертвувати
знаєте мої діти будуть їсти картоплю
сосисками можливо і я трохи з'їм просто
тепер багато в чому доводиться
обмежувати себе
таскхан відкрив також кафе де подають
недорогу гарячу їжу ним керують
волонтери
Сімона приходять Майже щодня обидві
мають проблеми із психічним здоров'ям
трапи за яку вони розділяють тут разом
це часто єдиний час коли вони виходять
із дому
це особливе місце тут безпечно
обстановка весь персонал дуже
доброзичливий і якщо в тебе був поганий
день ти завжди знайдеш когось хто прийде
і підтримає тебе Ти не можеш собі
дозволити харчуватися в іншому місці це
було просто не по кишені а тут це
доступно і ви можете залишатися тут
скільки захочете
тасхан запропонував меру Лондона
підтримати його наступний проект
навчання людей які залишилися без роботи
щоб вони могли знайти роботу у харчовій
і ресторанні індустрії
мер пообіцяв підтримку
та з надихає людей Лондонський
громадський продовольчий банк буквально
визначає різницю між життям і смертю для
вразливих сімей у нашому місті Мені
соромно що одна з найбагатших країн одне
з найбагатших місць світу потребує таких
закладів але реальність така що це
дійсно потрібно
продовольча криза зростає по всій країні
кожна четверта дитина у Великій Британії
щодня не доїдає Тобто кожна четверта
дитина не отримує їжі кожного дня
Ось така ситуація зараз і що нас чекає
майбутньому я не знаю
[музика]
тасхан ніколи не покладався на
очікування дій від інших навіть від
уряду і Цієї зими він сповнений
рішучості допомогти якомога більшій
кількості людей
[музика]
із Великої Британії вирушимо далі на
північ до Норвегії рибальство було там
головною у галузі промисловості і
славетної традицією протягом століть але
в останні кілька років рибні запаси
скоротилися і цей бізнес став менш
прибутковим привабливим для рибалок
більшість із яких чоловіки але одну
жінку - це не зупинило інгер Марі
хойланд обожнює свою професію це важка
робота за яку донедавнього часу бралося
не так багато жінок уряд Норвегії
намагається змінити цю ситуацію
забезпечуючи умови праці більш
сприятливі для створення сім'ї ідея в
тому щоб заохотити більше жінок до
кар'єри рибалки як це робить інгер Марія
яка працює у Водах біля острова сотра
інгер маріхойланд насолоджується виходом
у бурхливі води на своєму судні
щодня у дощів спеку Вона виходить у
Фіорди західної Норвегії
вони з батьком Працюють як одна команда
витягаючи сітки
інгер Марія і її батько так про нас
кажуть тотешні рибалки це сприймається
як належне дивно що в інших місцях це
може бути чимось особливим
представниця меншини
на кінець 2021 року у Норвегії
налічувалося майже 10 тисяч професійних
рибалок але лише 400 із них були жінками
Highland не може цього зрозуміти
Мені подобається бути на свіжому повітрі
і займатись фізичною роботою
риба - це природний ресурс
і риболовля це норвезька традиція Я хочу
зберегти цю традицію
було сьогодні був меншим ніж вони
сподівалися
прибережні рибалки не заробляють великі
грошей у Норвегії
той хто хоче швидко заробити займається
риборозведенням тому кнут магне-хойленд
радий що його донька ніколи не цуралась
важкої праці та складних умов
ще в дитинстві вона цікавилася
риболовлею і сьогодні це вже не дивина
добре що на жінок більше не покладається
лише приготування їжі
Highland мати-одиначка коли вона
повертається із моря на неї чекає
домашнє господарство і двоє дітей Вона
живе з ними на батьківській фермі
з грошима в неї скрутно але для своїх
дітей Вона взірець для наслідування
я не думаю що зміг би довго витримати
великому місті
тут на узбережжі
Брід села інстебу із норвезької
асоціації рибалок пишається тим що
сьогодні Highland більше не виняток
деталі більше молодих жінок піднімається
на борт рибальських суден тоді як
чоловіки починають покидати цю галузь
уряд Норвегії надає все більшу підтримку
молодим жінкам які хочуть стати
рибалками
якщо колега вагітна чи має доглядати за
маленькими дітьми то тимчасова заміна
чоловік чи жінка буде оплачуватися для
роботи на території промисло колеги
робота на великих траулерах також може
бути привабливою для молодих жінок
згідно з Законом після місяця роботи на
судні надається місячна відпустка
хайленд везе свій ловдопункту збору
там вона зустріла одного зі своїх колег
розмова йде про двигуни для човнів та
штурмовий захист жінки рибалки стають
все більш звичним явищем у Норвегії
У нас тут є кілька жінок рибалок зараз
і мої власні доньки вже 10 років
виходять у море
Але не всі колеги чоловіки такі привітні
як це було одного разу кілька років тому
коли вона допомагала на траурі біля
Північного узбережжя Норвегії
там був хлопець який дуже чітко дав
зрозуміти що він не хоче бачити жінок
Ані на Кораблі Ані в доках він ставився
до мене так ніби мене не існує
але інгер маріхойленд не збилася з курсу
вона рибалить у фіордах з 14 років і
хоче надихнути інших жінок брати з неї
приклад
це важка праця але цей особливий спосіб
життя
спосіб життя який починає приваблювати
все більше і більше жінок у Норвегії
в Україні люди живуть серед руїн війна й
російські ракети перетворили на попелища
багато міст і містечок зокрема і багато
футбольних полів але українці не падають
духом футбол завжди був популярним видом
спорту і зараз це особливо приємний
перепочинок проте багато тренувань та
матчів перериваються через обстріли А
страх не дає спокою але тренер Сергій
Павлюк не здається коли він викликає
своїх підопічних на поле молот
налаштована викластись на повну
Різдвяні свята це також сезон пошти
листи листівки посилки та бандеролі
розлітаються по всьому світу але якщо ви
відправляєте щось на французькій острів
ла-рейон то доставка може зайняти деякий
час оскільки він знаходиться далеко в
індійському океані і дістатися туди не
так просто сіріл Майло працює там
листоношею щоб доставити листи і посилки
у віддалені села він часто йде кілька
днів пішки
ранок понеділка і поштовий фургон
зупиняється перед будинком сіріла Майло
його батько йоланд привіз пошту для його
щотижневого маршруту
фургоні іди її забери
Йоганн знає що чекає на сіріла попереду
Іноді він сам ходив цим маршрутом поки
10 років тому сіріл не взяв його на себе
іоланду завжди подобалося брати з собою
сина
йому володіють коли він вперше пішов зі
мною ходити по маршруту із батьком це
була велика частина мого дитинства
тоді листоноші були інші обов'язки
ми приносили жителям гроші з банку сюди
в Долину або вкладали їх у банк за них
якщо комусь треба було заповнити якийсь
документ Ми робили це за них
часто ми зчитували листи бо там майже
ніхто не вмів читати сьогодні все інакше
діти в долині вже виросли і навчилися
читати і писати
через годину поїздки дорога закінчується
вирушає далі пішки гірськими стежками
мафати
весь маршрут займе два дні
доставити пошту всього до 50 поштових
скриньок це чималі зусилля у селі марла
близько 30 будинків
бачите на Поштовій скриньці немає імені
тут треба знати всіх і кожного і де вони
живуть
у місті є таблички з прізвищами і
номерами будинків а тут ні
який що понеділка сірі лучує в хостелі
яким вже 30 років керує пауліна хором
він приходить щотижня а він частина
сім'ї Він мені як син
Луна п'яти покоління своєї родини в
цьому гірському регіоні ла-рейон
місцевість була заселена в 19-му
столітті
мої предки знайшли тут прихисток коли
втекли з рабства
де втекли з узбережжя і сховалися у
горах
ми жили з того що могли виростити
Наступного дня сіріл має пройти близько
4 годин пішки
але І це йому подобається
ти просто повністю перемикаєшся
чекаєш подалі від міського життя
національний парк мавфате об’єкта
всесвітньої культурної спадщини Юнеско
жителі платять щорічну плату
французькому національному Лісовому
управлінню яке керує гірським
заповідником агентство обслуговує
гірські дороги і прибирає сміття яке раз
на місяць вивозять гелікоптером але зі
зростанням туризму це стає все більшою
проблемою
люди приїжджають з дідусіль і просто
залишають своє сміття де завгодно Колись
ми потонемо в смітті
А люди в мафати не хочуть щоб туристи
перестали приїжджати Вони приносять
гроші в село сільвом бег пам'ятає як
було раніше
життя було важким
багато людей не мали що їсти і
вирощували кукурудзу
приблизно в 1980 році є відкрив перший
хостел і ресторан
потім я відкрив інші хостели якби не
туристи ми б досі жили в злиднях
не просто розносить пошту він ще й
збирає її і відносить у долину його
робота листоношею має велике значення
для нього
люди тут як друзі а робота - це частина
мене Якби я перестав на його займатися
Це залишило б у моєму житті величезну
діру
до зустрічі
це гарне життя каже сіріумайло листоноша
з мафати
якщо ви любите зимові види спорту
швейцарські Альпи запропонують вам
чудовий досвід Але часто ці захоплюючі
схили не були придатними для катання на
лижах без допомоги снігових гармат
особливо на більш низьких висотах
курорти залежать від штучного снігу Це
завдає шкоди довкіллю і витрачає Гіга
вати електроенергії і все це в той час
коли через енергетичну кризу Європа
замерзає у швейцарському регіоні і юнк
фрау курорти рішуче налаштовані не
відключати гармати
ідеальний гірськолижний спуск
[музика]
швейцарський гірськолижний регіон юн
фрау може похизуватися більше ніж двома
тисячами кілометрів гірськолижних трас і
безліч у снігових гармати Які створюють
сніг коли матінка природа не така щедра
на нього
дві третини снігу тут це штучний сніг як
його називають в індустрії Такі люди як
петернет
виглядає непогано
для виготовлення штучного снігу потрібно
6-8 людей які працюють цілодобово
хтось буде спати чи просто відпочивати а
інші троє-четверо працюватимуть на схилі
Це високотехнологічна справа
ратраки обладнані спеціальною GPS
системою яка вимірює сніговий покрив на
схилі
раніше без GPS це було неможливо
ми часто виробляли більше снігу який
збирався б на тій чи іншій ділянці був
не потрібен весь сезон
Зараз ми можемо виробляти на 30% менше
штучного снігу
у швейцарському регіоні юн фрау працює
320 снігових гармат
вони з'єднані підземною системою водяних
труб
це була велика інвестиція яка обійшлася
у понад 38 мільйонів євро вода надходить
з водосховищ а електроенергія з
гідроелектростанцій Це величезне
підприємство але воно вигідно для галузі
у швейцарських Альпах кожна четверта
робоче місце залежить від зимового
туризму і експерти галузі кажуть що
відпочивальники стали більш вибагливими
гості очікують що буде сніг вони
очікують що всі траси будуть відкритими
для катання і жодна з них не буде
закритою через відсутність снігу під час
зимового сезону курортні міста тут
переповнені гостями які хочуть
покататися на лижах і санчатах
Зараз близько 53% гірськолижних трас у
Швейцарії покладаються на штучний сніг і
ця цифра зростає
екологи кажуть що таке високе
використання енергії та води не є
раціональним
кліматолог ретокнуті очікує Що глобальне
потепління змусить залишитись снігові
гармати в минулому Він вважає що вже
невдовзі половина всіх швейцарських
гірськолижних схилів будуть занадто
теплими і навіть штучний сніг не зможе
змінити ситуацію
гірськолижний туризм повинен бути
зосереджуватися на високогірних регіонах
на висоті 1500 200 метрів і вище нижчі
Регіони з часом стануть економічно
нежиттєздатними
регіон фрау знаходиться високо в Альпах
тож принаймні поки що він продовжуватиме
радувати любителів зимових видів спорту
зі снігом ЧБ за Схоже що принаймні цього
року вони зможуть порозважатися А на
сьогодні це все від імені всієї нашої
команди я бажаю вам чудових свят і
щасливого Нового року до побачення до
наступних зустрічей
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2022 рік
[музика]